au début elle m'a donné des choses
un équilibre parfait un sommeil parfait elle
veut entrer en moi je la sens elle
peut me voir
[Musique]
quand tu danses la danse d'un autre tu
te fais à l'image de son
créateur j'ai l'impression  Je ne suis même pas ici,
tu as jeté comme une sorte de façon qu'elle a
transmise au travail, tu dois décider
ce que tu veux être pour cette
entreprise, il y a plus dans ce bâtiment
que ce que tu peux voir d'autres
personnes dangereuses trois mères jouent à Dieu la taverne
mère locataire  nous nous émerveillons mère
cecelio obscurité faisant une sorte
de rythme d'affaire
Je ne sais pas de quoi tu parles
[Musique]
Oh
[Musique
] celui qui arrive
[Musique]
toi